i i remember i i wanted to stay there
for a year bro actually when i got out
saturday i don't know
when he came back on saturday he cried
the whole plane ride home
yeah he was like because you know you
you start to kind of connect the dots
about your life
and you're very clear because you're
sober in this place and you have all the
support
and now you you're on a plane to go home
with all the things that have either
made you happy or sad and you have to
mitigate that on your own and you're not
so sure
that a week's worth of the help is going
to
kind of uh um has put you on the right
path or not or if it's enough
or can you can you manage so that that
it's it's scary
yeah it's real scary that's how you went
there for a week yeah and friday
there was this dude in my group there
i'm not gonna say his name
it doesn't matter i know okay i'm gonna
say that can i guess one person
no you have to say yes or no all right
go ahead i'm just gonna guess
um
[Music]
let me think
i'll tell you this if you get it right
i'll give you 10 billion dollars
jesus 10 billion dollars
he's rich you know what i always
probably america's money's probably on
the loan isn't it you know what i just
got bro what
the core you did earth oh did you you
know the thing that goes
to make the gravity stop right here bro
[ __ ] you elon
wow you got that score earth core bro
yeah good luck keeping that somewhere
yeah great what is going to get it you
idiot i know
dude um i'll just tell you who it is man
and i i remember leaving
levi that's him levi
you got you got the core bro
congratulations no i didn't you got to
keep it what did you say
i i was in a group from new york i
hugged them we cried in each other's
arms
for like five minutes i never had that
kind of connection with another dude
before
damn right and so when i left that place
i was like
i don't want to leave but then how am i
gonna so i'm
trying to bro i'm just trying to get to
the point where you were like hugging
each other's arms
go back cry i think i want to see that
now are you able to hug each other for a
whole minute
deeply no we're not
are we without a bit
without laughing and making it a bit
okay yeah i could do that easily i think
two minutes one minute one minute let's
put a timer on
here i'll put the timer on go in that
over there i'm gonna move but if you
laugh bro we start over the time starts
over who has a timer i have a timer
this is going to be
yeah you can't laugh right smile or
laugh you got to be serious
hold on make the rules clear oh i'll
make the rules right now here's what it
is it's already a bit all right
i don't like unclear rules
there's there's dialogue too we can't
talk during it no we have a little
dialogue and i'm going to give you your
script
you can memorize it right see now it's a
bit
no it's not a bill no farewell my friend
all right
and i'll say adios amigo whatever line
you want you want adios amigo
that's a bit it's not it's it's a scene
no it's not a scene it should be
just two people hugging each other and
forming a connection
heart to
[Music]
hello shout out to the vietnamese in
louisiana too
cajun crawfish five about 50 states for
vietnamese people i'll start the timer
when you guys hug
sorry i'm sorry i need a second i'm good
okay i'll die there he goes and no don't
do two it's too rushed
it's too rushed what it's intimacy
huh intimacy all right
[Music]
and time begins now
what is it
oh [ __ ] it's only 20 seconds
fall into it bobby be real hold the man
all right don't tap
think about all the things you love
about each other
he's asleep i think here we go
you smell a little bit older that though
we're almost there guys
all right reaching about a minute we're
at the minute mark
they did half the time you said one
minute you said two minutes no i
went back to one minute oh you changed
it yeah yeah nobody's hugging for two
minutes bro
yeah people have stuff to do man it's
crazy
does it feel like hey bro but it's still
a minute people still got stuff to do
irishman irishman
i won't even watch it it's horrible i'm
not watching somebody for three and a
half hours dude
we should see it for sebastian though
yeah but they can cut his scenes
together and send it to you yeah give me
your real sense
i'm not gonna watch the [ __ ] movie
hey guys we're gonna take a quick break
to share some of our favorite sponsors
with you blue
apron the tastiest food you'll ever
have it's so good for you it's healthy
as [ __ ]
you guys when i come home from a hard
day's of work of doing nothing
and i drive up on the driveway